on
la grève des cheminots massivement suivi
des millions de français ont fait le
pied de grue devant des rails
désespérément vide
michael gorbatchev ne quittera pas son
poste de secrétaire général du parti le
numéro un soviétique a formellement
démenti la rumeur lancée par une
télévision américaine
il est désormais chevalier des arts et
des lettres mais ils sont toujours deux
concerts exceptionnels au rex bob dylan
ou l'éternel retour
bonsoir françois mitterrand a invité
aujourd'hui le gouvernement à être très
attentif à l'évolution de la situation
en allemagne et en europe orientale si
le chef de l'état a tenu ces propos sur
un ton solennel
c'est par ce qu'il perçoit bien comme
tous les leaders occidentaux
la dramatisation du débat politique en
union soviétique notamment les deux
grandes questions du jour porte sur la
position de mikhaïl gorbatchev qui reste
bien le chef du parti communiste mais
qui semble fragilisé et sur
l'éventualité je devrais dire la
probabilité d'une réunification des deux
allemagnes c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons invité ce soir vladimir
fédorovski conseiller de l'ambassade
soviétique à paris et jean pierre
chevènement ministre de la défense qui
vient de faire une déclaration
importante devant l'école de guerre le
19 20 en aura la primeur
nous vous retrouverons dans un instant
messieurs après le premier dossier de ce
journal qui intéresse tous les français
parce qu'il porte sur notre vie
quotidienne
il s'agit de la grève des transports qui
a provoqué de grosses perturbations dans
de nombreuses villes du pays
jacques bernier fait un bilan grâce aux
images d'une station régionale journée
grise aujourd'hui la sncf débrayé et en
moyenne un train sur quatre a circulé au
départ des gares du nord de l'est de
lyon d'austerlitz en ce qui concerne les
trains de banlieue à l'exception de
paris saint-lazare où le service était
totalement interrompu sur certaines
lignes sur les grandes lignes la sncf a
pu réaliser au moins une relation dans
chaque sens entre paris et les grandes
métropoles 1 tgv sur 4 à circuler la
direction de la sncf prévoit un retour à
la normale à partir de jeudi sur les
principales lignes de banlieue et sur le
réseau national à paris le rer le métro
et les autobus ont circulé normalement
au débrayage des cheminots s'est ajouté
ce matin les hoquets des chauffeurs de
taxis parisiens
ces derniers ont manifesté leur
mécontentement devant le ministère des
finances
le personnel au sol d'air à terre qui
s'inquiète de la prise de contrôle par
air france a débrayé pendant 4 heures ce
matin principalement orly ouest
mais ces mouvements n'ont aucunement
perturbé les départs et les arrivées de
la compagnie
les cheminots ont rouleront à nouveau
pour vous dès demain le trafic devrait
redevenir normale à partir de 9h du
matin mais faisons tout de même un point
dans plusieurs villes en direct nous
allons commencer par paris et la région
avec morad aït habbouche qui se trouve à
la gare saint-lazare mourad oui paul
logiquement entre 17 heures et 20 heures
le trafic ici à la gare saint-lazare
c'est à peu près de 200000 personnes
bien sûr avec la grève 80% visiblement
chez les cheminots
la situation s'est compliquée avec nous
deux personnes vous habitez evreux c'est
à une heure à peu près de paris vous
êtes parti à quelle heure ce matin de
d'evreux à cette heure et vous êtes
arrivé à quelle heure à paris un nouvel
ennemi en temps normal vous mettez
combien de temps une heure c'est ça une
wii vous êtes fait réprimander par votre
patron
drôlement et alors ce soir est ce que
vous avez un moyen de repartir du touch
est bloqué à dire que la zone où alors
vous allez faire comment comment vous
allez faire comment pour repartir sur et
et vous monsieur donc vous avez utilisé
le système d vous avez vous habitez où
exactement
j'habite colombes je suis allé à la gare
du stade c'est n'y avait rien c'était
fermé
je suis allé à pied
la gare de colombes donc fois il y avait
rien eu depuis le matin alors j'ai pris
le bus
jusqu à asnières et puis ensuite le
métro bon évidemment ça a été plus long
que d'habitude
j'habite pas loin mais enfin c'est quand
même plus long que d'habitude
merci comme vous pouvez l'entendre
derrière moi bien sûr l'exaspération
monte et on le comprend
certains ont dû attendre comme ce
monsieur 1h 1h30 peut-être ils vont
rester ce soir gare saint lazare
en tout cas demain on peut le dire et
c'est peut-être un réconfort pour tous
les passagers à 6 heures la situation
devrait redevenir normale voilà paul
situation en direct de la gare
saint-lazare merci merci mourad allons
maintenant à lyon où se trouve mathilde
pradier a lyon la journée a été
difficile pour les usagers des
transports en commun un bus sur trois
selon la direction un sur cinq selon les
syndicats circuler dans l'agglomération
la grève du personnel roulant touché
également le métro de lignes
fonctionnent et la troisième était
totalement bloquée les lyonnais ont donc
pris leur voiture d'où des bouchons
supplémentaires aux abords de fourvière
et les associations de consommateurs
iron dôme à soutenir les syndicats
devant le siège des tcl les transports
en commun lyonnais
tout le monde est bien consciente à
l'heure où se succèdent les alertes à la
pollution
il faut absolument réformer la marche
des transports en commun en fin de
journée aucune négociation n'avait
abouti avec la direction et les
syndicats n'excluent pas de poursuivre
le mouvement dans les prochains jours
sur le front sncf direction et syndicats
quand des tubes de 60% de green un tgv
sur quatre seulement fonctionner
aujourd'hui
et là aussi même si le travail de
reprendre normalement demain les
syndicats annoncent de nouvelles actions
pour les jours à venir
dernière étape de ce mini tour de france
réalisé grâce à nos stations régionales
lille nous appelons en direct michel
bart seashell oui
lille c'est la première gare voyageurs
de province ici transitent chaque jour
80 mille personnes un peu moins de la
moitié du total de la région ils sont
transportés par 520 trains régionaux et
une centaine de trains grandes lignes le
plan d'urgence de première urgence
prévoyait 185 train de région il n'a pas
pu être remplie puisque 164 rames
seulement ont circulé même proportion
d'un tiers environ pour le service
grandes lignes dans certains secteurs
sur la petite ligne de valenciennes à
cambrai par exemple les trains ont été
déviés et plusieurs gars ont même été
totalement fermé pourtant la direction
régionale n'a recensé que 35% de
grévistes proportions un peu plus forte
chez les roulants près de la moitié mais
parmi les personnels d'exploitation la
grève de certains agents à la fonction
un peu plus stratégique à empêcher
certains trains de rouler le retour à la
normale est prévue progressivement
demain matin et tout à fait aux environs
de midi merci michel vous imaginez les
raisons de tous ces mouvements d'humeur
elles tiennent en un mot rémunération
mais à la sncf elle porte sur une autre
question le statut de l'entreprise
les cheminots le craignent que ce statut
changer craignent surtout que l'esprit
services publics disparaissent
samuel costa après bape nous en dit plus
pour la première fois depuis dix ans un
excédent d'exploitation de 200 millions
de francs pour la sncf grâce à quoi
entre autres à une augmentation des
voyageurs de près de 2%
le ferai aussi 1,6 le tgv à lui seul a
fait plus 4,2 pour cent simplement voilà
1990 et le début du nouveau contrat plan
de cinq ans buts essentiels la
productivité investir 43 milliards de
francs dans le tgv 15 milliards dans le
réseau banlieue et une refonte totale du
secteur marchandises avec aussi la
suppression de 4500 emplois par an si
nécessaire mais avec une éventuelle
embauche
les syndicats ne sont pas du tout
d'accord il estime que la direction
privilégie les investissements rentables
comme le tgv laissant pour compte les
liaisons transversales et les petites
desserte et du même coup la notion de
service public
si on y ajoute des revendications
salariales avec une hausse
r 2 2% hors primes jugées insuffisantes
on obtient un cocktail explosif
la preuve tous les syndicats ont adhéré
au mouvement sauf la cgc qu'il
représente qu'un pour cent du personnel
tous les fonctionnaires doivent suivre
avec une grande attention la négociation
qui a repris cet après midi entre les
représentants syndicaux et le ministre
de la fonction publique michel durafour
la cgt a préféré boycotter la réunion
mais les autres participants semblent
être optimiste michel rocard également
il y a espoir at-il dit ce matin au
conseil des ministres si un accord aussi
un désaccord survient au cours de ce
journal henry lauret qui suit cette
discussion nous en informera aussi tôt
michael gorbatchev a tenu aujourd'hui à
démentir la rumeur qui a affolé hier le
monde occidental il n'a pas démissionné
de son poste de secrétaire général du
parti communiste d'union soviétique
il se demande d'ailleurs si cette rumeur
n'a pas été propagée par ses adversaires
politiques à moscou jean marc pitte cnn
la chaîne américaine d'information
permanente
hier soir le présentateur lance le scoop
du correspondant à moscou
mirel gorbatchev serait prêt à
démissionner de son poste de secrétaire
général du parti communiste pour se
consacrer à sa fonction présidentielle
le secrétariat d'état américain dans le
même temps annonce le report de la
visite de james baker à son homologue
soviétique
edouard chevardnadzé à moscou
l'ambassadeur américain se dit incapable
d'infirmer ou de confirmer la nouvelle
cette incertitude sème la panique à la
bourse de new york l'indicé dow jones
chute de 40 points avant de se redresser
pour limiter ses pertes à 10 points pour
achever la rumeur il faudra un démenti
de l'intéressé lui même alors qu'il
reçoit le nouveau président du brésil
michael gorbatchev nie catégoriquement
personne n'a dit cela et moi même je
n'ai jamais fait une telle déclaration
le numéro un soviétique ira jusqu'à
demander à qui profite ce genre de
rumeur pour y répondre il faut d'abord
savoir qu'il a fait naître
alors messieurs fédéraux ce qui vous est
le conseiller de l'ambassade d'une en
génétique à paris qui a fait naître
cette rumeur mais il faut demander quels
sont les dessous de source que quel
sacré responsabilité des journalistes
c'est difficile à dire puisque je ne
crois pas que le correspondant de cnn à
donner en france soultz
vraiment si on se demande pourquoi mais
vous connaissez le professionnalisme de
nos confrères américains n'ont pas donné
comme ça gratuitement
c'est ce qui m'étonne le plus dans ce
contexte là je crois bien que peut-être
il ya des gens qui ont l'intérêt de
nostalgiques de la guerre froide je ne
sais pas quelqu'un à l'intérieur tout
est possible face au maire était au fond
je ne sais pas mais surtout je pourrais
bien qu'il faut voir clair que peut-être
le contraire de ce qu'on pense qui est
en train de se produire
gorbatchev est bien en place il n'ya pas
enfin il n'y a pas de lieu de donner ce
genre de rumeurs et qu'on me disait un
grand écrivain américain autrefois la
nouvelle de ma mort est exagéré mais
enfin vous savez quand même les
adversaires ont encore du poids et
notamment les conservateurs et je sais
que et le monde l'a dit hier certains
des conseillers de gorbatchev le pousse
à aller encore plus loin
vous savez je crois bien que vos boîtes
chaud il est en train d'aller très loin
et le plénum du comité central dans
quelques jours ce sera un étape décisive
qu'est ce qu'on attend de ce plénum au
fait on attend surtout l'accélération
des réformes et les réformes non
seulement dans le domaine économique
mais des réformes politiques qui sont
importants aux importantes
important aussi enfin dans le cadre des
activités du parti
donc vous dites très clairement j'ai
entendu que la position de ratchet et
pas aussi fragile qu'on le croie en
occident je ne peux je ne pense pas et
l'acculturation absolument pas
absolument pas vous savez il y a enfin
il ya je connais tous d'avoir mes
sources
si vous nous permettez mais d'autre part
je regarde enfin à la réalité de
l'enfant des tendances de l'opinion
publique dans mon pays vous savez le
mouvement qui a été commencé d'en haut
enfin était en train de l'enfant d'être
soutenus réellement soutenu par les
forces qui sont présents en bas regardez
la situation dans les provinces
soviétique les gens par les milliers
sortent dans les rues souvent contre
certains ont tant pouvoir le coup mais
regardez toujours avec les slogans pro
gold beach aux blues de raifort vous pas
c'est ça qui est très important la
journée souci vous savez on peut donner
beaucoup de
enfin d'informations à ce sujet ma fille
la première question aujourd'hui
comment va gourbi c'est très
significatif il ya quelques années
c'était impensable
il vous pensez qu'il doit rester à la
tête du parti à la prochaine de l'état
est numéro un du parti communiste doit
simuler oui vous savez je vais vous
donner mon avis personnel tout ce qui va
dans le sens de consolidation des forces
qui sont pour les réformes doit être
fait et je pense mais je pense que dans
le moment actuel cette cumulation enfin
des fonctions joue pour consolidation
des forces réformistes dans mon pays
mais vous et lien comme ça mais on
extrait pas un jour l'élection
présidentielle et y compris phrase
universel direct comme chez nous en
france veut écouter on peut rien exclure
de relaxer relation de l'histoire c'est
en fait mais pour le moment je dis
encore une fois il faut voir clair ce
qui se passe et regardez bien ce source
merci monsieur fédorovski la situation
l'union soviétique a fait l'objet d'une
conversation téléphonique entre michael
gorbatchev et george bush aujourd'hui
les deux hommes d'état ont sans doute
parler également de la question qui
émerge et qui fera l'objet du débat des
années 90 la réunification des deux
allemagnes elle semble inéluctable
d'autant plus que mikhaïl gorbatchev a
donné son feu vert francine raymond la
question d'une patrie allemande unis
fataland ainsi parlait en mode raw à
l'issue de son entretien avec michael
gorbatchev hier les mots sont lâchés
jusque là le numéro 1 stalmans négocier
prudemment avec son homologue ouest
allemand helmut khol de la mise en place
d'une communauté contractuelle entre les
deux allemagnes il revient en rda avec
le feu vert de moscou pour s'engager
dans un vrai processus d'union avec la
rfa toutes les semaines depuis la chute
du mur par centaines de milliers les
allemands de l'est réclame cette
unification éviter le pire des scénarios
que la question allemande soit résolu
sous la pression de la rue c'est le
souci majeur de mikhaïl gorbatchev
pour le numéro un soviétique c'est clair
personne ne pourra jamais par principe
mettre en doute une union des deux
allemagnes de processus est irréversible
il reste à répondre à la principale
question posée par le rapprochement des
deux états allemands à savoir la vue
neuf militaires autant pacte de varsovie
nous la rfa et de la rda sont des
maillons essentiels
est-ce que l'union soviétique entre les
troupes quitteront un jour l'allemagne
de l'est et berlin enfin vous savez
c'est une question qu'on compte peut
poser toujours mais quand on pose ce
genre de questions il faut toujours
garder je crois bien en tête une chose
aller cette évolution dans l'europe
d'aujourd'hui doit être fait doit être
fait dans le cadre de la stabilité
je rejoins tout à fait enfin les idées
françaises si vous voulez bien à ce
sujet il y a ce très important que
l'europe soit solide mais dans le cadre
de la stabilité un seul mois avant de
parler de l'objet de votre venue ici sur
ce point précis le retrait des troupes d
vainqueur de la lan dresser vers un
événement que je crois savoir que
certaines décision pourrait être
annoncée sous peu
on va vers certaines réductions
maintenant ce qui est important c'est de
maintenir la paix sur notre continent et
qui dit p10 équilibre on peut progresser
vers un moindre niveau d'armement mais
il faut veiller à maintenir les
équilibres qui sont les garants de la
paix alors merci précisément cette
éventualité nous amène à parler du
désarmement
il y a désormais un fort courant en
union soviétique les états unis
favorable à une réduction importante des
armes stationnées en europe françois
mitterrand george bush en ont parlé
samedi dernier le téléphone fonctionne
beaucoup en ce moment
le chef de l'état français qui suit de
très près ce dossier tient compte
évidemment de l'état des armées
françaises j'allais dire des états d'âme
de l'armée de terre aujourd'hui qui se
demande s'il ne veut pas subir les
conséquences de ce désarmement
pierre babey
c'est l'un des spectacles les plus
surréalistes de ce début des années 90 à
berlin la garnison française continue de
s'entraîner contre une attaque des
troupes soviétiques combats de rue
explosion rien n'y manque rien sauf
l'adversaire car dans le même temps les
ordres de blindés de l'armée rouge
s'apprête à regagner leurs frontières
les soviétiques joue ainsi le plus
mauvais tour aux militaires français il
les prive d'une menace or sans menace
clairement perçu difficile de faire
accepter qu'il faut autant d'hommes de
matériel d'argent que du temps de la
guerre froide alors l'armée de terre
voit se profiler destruction de matériel
diminutions d'effectifs contraction
budget un exemple sur les 1350 chars de
bataille l'armée devrait être supprimée
15 % et ce n'est qu'un début
résultat paradoxal du désarmement il
inquiète alors qu'il devrait soulager
aujourd'hui le blues à une couleur le
cac alors j'imagine que on vous a
entendu avec beaucoup d'attention cet
après midi devant l'école de guerre
parce que vous avez fait allusion au
désarmement et à l'état des armées
françaises michèle ministre oui mais je
dois vous dire que la manière dont les
choses sont présentées ne correspond pas
à la réalité
d'abord parce que ne vont jamais
considéré que nous avions un ennemi
désigné qui serait l'union soviétique
la défense française et pour garantir la
liberté indépendance de la france pour
dissuader tout agresseur quel qu'il soit
toutes menaces d'où qu'elles viennent et
aujourd'hui disons que nous voyons avec
beaucoup d'intérêt ce qui se passe sur
niant soviétique
nous souhaitons le succès de michael
gorbatchev mais la carte de l'europe
bouge il se passe beaucoup de choses
les téléspectateurs français il voit
aussi je dirais ce qui se passe en
roumanie en azerbaïdjan dans les pays
baltes et ils se rendent compte que le
moyen orient est une zone chaude du club
qu'il y a un défi qui vient du sud qui
est celui du fanatisme religieux de
l'intégrisme qui appartient d'ailleurs
pas qu'à une seule religion
donc je dirais que notre défense c'est
une défense qui a pour but simplement la
liberté du pays c'est une posture
défensive et ont cité à l'instant le
nombre de nos chars 13 105 ans
mais monsieur fédorovski ne me démentira
pas il y actuellement d'après le pacte
de varsovie 57000 char du côté du pacte
de varsovie et selon les calculs du
parti de varsovie un peu plus de 30000
du côté de l'alliance atlantique et en
avoue elle-même 27000 et notre objectif
c'est d'arriver à 20000 de part et
d'autre n'est ce pas est bien très 150
sur 20000 c'est 6 5% du total
vous voyez que notre défense elle est
fondée sur la dissuasion suffisante à un
niveau de suffisance est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure aux cours supérieur
interarmées
c'est que naturellement nous prendrions
notre part des réductions canard est
quand un accord sera conclu à vienne
mais c'est oui mais c'est qu'elle n'a
pas lieu d'être inquiète parce que
forcément étant donné nos effectifs sur
mes terres ses 290 1000 hommes je crois
ne pas exagérer en disant que l'armée
soviétique aujourd'hui à 4 millions
d'hommes et il faudra du temps pour
réduire ses effectifs ça ne peut pas se
faire du jour au lendemain de berlin on
doit le choisir almrei seief a dit qu'il
fallait aller jusqu'au au moins 1997
pour faire ces réductions
on retrouve à étaler dans le temps on va
étaler dans le temps
des réductions qui seront nécessairement
très modéré le jour où il y aura
évidemment un accord question rapide
réponse rapide retrait des tons
française de l'allemagne de l'est au nom
de l'allemagne de l'est hélas on parlera
de berlin avait pour le moment il y a un
statut de berlin qui engage les quatre
puissances alliées
nous devons en discuter entre nous et
avec les deux et allemand pour savoir
comment les choses peuvent évoluer
l'essentiel c'est ce qu'il faut bien
faire comprendre à ceux qui nous
écoutent sec notre but c'est de tête de
garantir la paix la stabilité
l'equilibre la sécurité ne voulons pas
revoir une nouvelle guerre en europe
nous avons trop souffert et je pense que
tous les peuples d'europe sont d'accord
pour cela donc nous avons faire baisser
le niveau les armements
mais maintenir un équilibre de sécurité
baissé dans quelle mesure la vraie pas
très clair pardonnez moi donc les
mesures
c'est très simple le but c'est de
réduire les asymétries commandes et dire
qu'il ya évidemment plus d'armes
conventionnelles d'un côté que de
l'autre mais en même temps il faut
discuter parce que le soviétique il dit
quand
il était dans le domaine et c'est bien
mais le jour où nous aurons un accord
qui va réduire les asymétries nous mêmes
je dirais du côté de l'alliance
atlantique la france ayant une posture
indépendante je vous le rappelle devront
faire un effort
un pur je dirais maintenir cette posture
défensive qui sera la garantie d'une
paix durable merci monsieur chevènement
merci monsieur fait d'euros ce qui
évidemment ne reviendrons sur ce thème
au cours de nos prochains journaux en
france ce troisième journée du procès
terroristes du terroriste fouad ali
saleh troisième audience marquée par
l'attitude de sa femme qui intrigue les
magistrats est elle coupable ou non
récit clément weill-raynal karima
ferrahi la femme de fouad ali saleh est
une épouse musulmane j'ai choisi d'être
soumise précise-t-elle au tribunal où
ils ne voient là chez elle on a
découvert des pistolets mitrailleurs des
explosifs le tout plus ou moins emballé
je suis une femme monsieur le procureur
explique-t-elle mon mari m'avait
interdit de poser des questions je ne
devais pas m'intéresser aux affaires des
hommes quand il y avait des invités à la
maison je m'enfermais dans la salle des
bains je mangeais dans un coin de la
pièce tout le portrait d'une épouse
soumise mais pour le procureur fourvel
la ficelle est un peu grosse
madame dit-il les policiers de la dst
vous ont vu portant des sacs en
plastique dans lequel s'entrechoquaient
des bouteilles d'anisette remplies de
liquides explosifs
vous ne vous êtes pas poser des
questions en portant ces sacs
non monsieur le procureur mon mari
m'avait habitué à marcher les yeux
baissés le procureur pendant plus d'une
heure d'interrogatoire aimerait bien
comprendre les motivations de cette
épouse modèle qui avait rencontré fouad
ali saleh à l'époque où elle vendait un
journal militant sur les marchés à
barbès à cette époque souligne le
procureur vous étiez plus politisé plus
émancipées moins religieuse moins
soumises les autres nouvelles du jour
hervé dino
la police yougoslave tire sans sommation
sur des habitants du village de malice
et vos kosovo faisant au moins quatre
morts touche d'origine albanaise
plusieurs témoins affirment que les
rafales meurtrières sont partis de trois
véhicules de la police qui traversait la
place centrale du village tout à fait
calme à cette heure de la journée
malisse et vaud avait déjà été le cadre
la semaine dernière de violents
affrontements qui avaient coûté la vie à
11 personnes
l'armée du général aoun une bombarde
depuis ce matin les positions des forces
libyennes
un secteur chrétiens à beyrouth
principal objet qui visait une caserne
située au bas de la colline d'achrafieh
le général aoun reproche toujours aux
forces libanaises de n'avoir pas pris
clairement position à propos de l'accord
de taëf fin de la cavale des quatre
détenus qui s'étaient évadés dimanche de
la maison d'arrêt de loos les lille
ils viennent d'être interpellé par les
gendarmes vers 5 ou pini dans le pas de
calais les quatre hommes avaient profité
de la promenade pour se faire la belle
réapparition tout aussi mystérieuse que
sa disparition pour abdoul farif captain
deux fondateurs de l'organisation
intégriste la voie de l'islam qui avait
été enlevé vendredi a donné de ses
nouvelles à la police ce matin là c'est
en avoir été ce prester de rang une
journée après sa libération il se serait
réfugié chez des amis dans la région de
grenoble d'un art trinquer le
commissaire du cercle juges chargés de
l'enquêté rendus sur les lieux demain 19
20 spéciales en direct de l'art de la
défense avec une première mondiale
une rencontre entre tous les jeunes
leaders de l'est ce soir 22h 15 marques
hautement en quelques secondes michel
pouré à demain 19h bonsoir
à